with a nine and five record the Atlanta
Falcons had in tomorrow's game with the
New Orleans Saints in the thick of the
NFL's postseason race ball team owner
Arthur Blank has built the Falcons into
a championship contender he has also
been the driving force behind the
construction of a world-class Stadium
for the team to play in but blank isn't
finished with his rebuilding plan
he hopes the stadium will be the
catalyst for change for an entire city
mercedes-benz stadium the 1.5 billion
dollar state-of-the-art home to the
NFL's Falcons and Major League Soccer's
Atlanta United from its elaborately
designed eight panel retractable roof to
its all inspiring 11 hundred foot halo
scoreboard it may look like a sporting
cathedral but according to the Falcons
president and CEO rich McKay it was
built to be more like a community center
Arthur's theory going in was let's not
look at Stadium locations let's not go
look at where we might put a stadium for
the best economics let's realize we're
gonna put the stadium downtown and we're
gonna try to put it right in the heart
of downtown the stadium is bordered by a
thriving commercial district to the
north and a dilapidated neighborhood to
the west over the years everybody has
thought or said build a stadium here it
will bring money to a city is that true
doesn't work not true what we were
saying to people was this stadium can be
a catalyst for change we can bring
everybody to the table we can make an
impact on the Westside but it won't just
be because we build the building once
home to civil rights legends like Martin
Luther King jr. and Julian Bond
Atlanta's historic West Side has become
one of the poorest neighborhoods in the
United States one that Falcons owner
Arthur Blank a co-founder of the Home
Depot wanted to help rebuild
when we began designed the stadium I
said you know we're gonna be committed
to the communities nearby particularly
on the west side which you know probably
thirty years ago had a population of
55,000 people it's down to about 10
percent of that now all the things you
look for in a healthy neighborhood they
had and then for a variety of reasons
that's gone downhill four years ago the
Arthur M Blanc Family Foundation started
dedicating substantial money and
resources to the West
Side neighborhood 37 million dollars has
already been committed that has some
longtime residents worrying about
gentrification others think real change
still will never come how much
skepticism did you get from a community
that obviously had been promised a lot
before a lot how do you deal with that I
think in my own case I had a fair amount
of credibility in Atlanta because of my
history in history of a foundation and I
think our early behavior they could see
was different is that we weren't there
to write write checks we were there to
understand the issues and then to
respond to the issues and respond to
them in a way that's really meaningful
this neighborhood is literally
overlooking the stadium behind us mm-hmm
it has some of the best it really has
the best view of the stadium in the city
Frank Fernandez was part of that
response hired to serve as a community
liaison for the Foundation's Westside
development project you can see
buildings that are been and you have
overgrown you have sidewalks that aren't
maintained you got busted out lights
Fernandez took us through the West Side
neighborhood if you were a person who
lives in poverty or a child born into
poverty in Atlanta you have only a 4%
chance moving out of poverty to the
higher income brackets and so our
commitment is geography should not
constitute destiny right and so how do
we help break that cycle of poverty and
how do we use this the stadium as a
catalyst for change the Foundation's
answer investing in the infrastructure
and people Atlanta's YMCA has relocated
its headquarters to the west side the
foundation has built homes for police
officers so they can live in the
neighborhood not just patrol it and
sponsors in the stadium were strongly
encouraged to invest in the community as
well like chick-fil-a and they're gonna
employ 80 people from the community at
this store all of our corporate partners
all 13 of them have committed to working
with us in the West Side have committed
nearly 15 million dollars one of the
things Frank said to us it it's not
going in there and saying we're fixing
this this place will do this it's doing
it together
they have to buy into it the end of the
day the answer can't be what we're
imposing on them we want them to say
these to make sense for us
and these two don't make sense for us so
we'll do the two that makes sense for
them
what's your measurement here seven seven
like Westside works a neighborhood
program started by the foundation
providing job training in fields like
Technology nursing construction and
culinary arts according to the group
more than 500 people have already been
placed in jobs that have brought in ten
and a half million dollars in income
people like Westside resident Tony
Thomas who one day hopes to have her own
food truck do you feel like it's changed
some attitudes because you're seeing
actual changes yeah because now people
they have hope now at first it wasn't
having hope so now you have a lot of
people that have a hope Thomas works at
the West nest in Mercedes Benz Stadium a
concession stand operated by fellow
graduates West nest and concessions
throughout the arena offer prices you
don't see in most professional sporting
facilities like five dollar beers along
with two dollar hot dogs and refillable
sodas where did that idea come from to
just say let's give people food that's
affordable in a stadium number one I was
always annoyed and irritated as a father
having to gone to stadiums and events
and paying you know ridiculous prices
for everything in the building and so
I'd hear fans just people around me just
complaining about it all the time so I
you know said time management think we
need to price it every day the same way
they would pay any place else they went
in the city of Atlanta you're a
businessman this sounds like this could
also help your bottom line and so we you
know I mean I think over time I think
we'll see that our volumes interrupts
dramatically but they weren't you know
Dana one of the reasons that we wanted
to do this was not just for the
mercedes-benz stadium is that if we can
rationalize and show people that it's
not only the right things for the fans
but it's the right thing for the
business as well we're hoping that we'll
set an example for other people not only
in Atlanta oh really but throughout the
United States blank says doing the right
thing is also at the heart of the West
Side Development Project as for
measuring those results so when is the
west side of success well it's it's I
think it's directionally a success now
you'll see the changes come over time
I mean my guests over the next you know
three four or five years you continue to
see very significant progress in a
variety of areas as you move towards
long long term solutions so I'm very
optimistic